cet été j'ai eu la chance de réaliser un
rêve de gosse je suis parti à à cause
des films américains j'ai l'impression
que le nom des villes américaines nous
paraissent toujours extrêmement style et
boston seattle chicago pittsburgh
j'aimerais tellement un jour dire à
quelqu'un juste pour le style à deux
mains demain je peux pas j'ai un truc à
faire à washington
moi j'adore le nom des villes en france
mais peut-être que la chanson new york à
d'alicia keys et jay-z
elle aurait un peu moins marcher avec
par exemple à bien
avec sa gas a porté son offre va
de m mais
alors grâce à ce séjour je parle de
moins en moins mal anglais assez cool
par contre mon accent anglais est
horrible estime les américains ne me
comprennent pas histoire vraie j'ai
demandé un jour à un monsieur
il a compris ouest boom qui ressemble
beaucoup à west hall 1 quant à un accent
de merde
d'ailleurs j'ai passé mon séjour à me
croire cool en balançant à tout le monde
ciao rest in peace by rest in peace et
c'est seulement la fin du séjour que
j'ai réalisé que ça voulait dire
repose en paix donc je passais pour un
mec plutôt morbide bail et repose en
paix bon au début j'ai eu un peu de mal
à m'adapter
par exemple quand j'ai vu la taille des
parts de pizza là-bas gens et de leur
dire est-ce que je peux avoir une part
de parts de pizza soubelet à new york
quand il fait très chaud en été dans les
lieux publics il met la clim glacial du
coup ton corps ne cesse de faire
chaleurs extrêmes froid glacial chaleur
extrême et moi mon corps il était pas
prêt à ça alors il réagi il s'est
exprimé et d'une manière plutôt élégante
dans ma tête la clim elle n'était pas
réglée sur froid elle était réglée sur
le mode je suis là une salle de sport la
clim est tellement forte je vous jure
c'est vrai j'ai couru et mon manteau
depuis la douche de ma chambre d'hôtel
j'avais une superbe vue sur new york
c'était vraiment magnifique
par contre au début ya un petit détail
que j'ai trouvé un petit plus chevaux
alors je me suis dit peut-être qu'à new
york fait comme ça les gens ils prennent
leur douche en rideau ils sont foutus a
alors j'ai fait avec new york
je me suis renseigné et j'ai découvert
que les mecs de l'hôtel ont juste oublié
mettre un rideau hamadouche génial j'ai
donc montrer ma [ __ ] à tout new york
times scolaire c'est un quartier
incroyable qu'il trouve plein de gens
excentrique a qui viennent partager leur
passion leur délire leurs convictions il
ya même des mecs qui font de la pub à
l'américaine mais pour leur religion
alors je respecte ça mais c'est quand
même un concept qui m'a un peu étonné
graal is great gallesio frère said in a
row church mailhac thank you like bruce
jackson preuve le nord pas de calais
mais là-bas à new york c'est la culture
de type du pourboire
c'est presque obligatoire des données
15% à 20% de la somme en plus quand tu
payes et les taxis pour augmenter leur
pouvoir ils veulent paraître sympa en
s'intéressant un patois mais en même
temps sans qu'ils sont un peu saoulé de
le faire à chaque client du coup ça
donne un mix bizarre de mec sympa mais
sous les voiles somme pareille au magal
et de s'installer là-bas et la farine à
tout le pays bigben a créé la techno
geek me five d'accord it's my lady ngo
le new york ils sont plutôt cool tout
cas ce que j'ai croisé était franchement
accueillant et marrant par exemple une
fois dans un resto j'ai demandé au
serveur le nom du wifi il m'a répondu
haro sur pizza good hockey sauvegarde
password good pizza imagine fait cette
blague dans un resto où les pizzas sont
des gueux comment tu as trouvé ta pizza
dégueulasse bah voilà le mot de passe
pizza dégueulasse pourquoi parle
français tout d'un coup la très très
bonne question je vais je vais en parler
à mon avis tu
j'ai même croisé certains d'entre vous
là bas à new york
les femmes font courir
je garde plein de souvenirs coup la tête
j'ai vraiment adoré ce voyage j'espère
que vous aussi vous aurez la chance
d'aller un jour à new york je voulais
finir en vous laissant sur le morceau
new york de jay-z alicia keys mais j'ai
pas les droits musicaux dessus alors je
vais vous faire ma petite version à moi
projetant snap complètement dangereux
aux bagages
pour la mort de la west indies suis dans
le présent bloquée dans la photo je suis
destiné à moman